Знімальна група ДВ у Грозному.
Після двох чеченських воєн місто відбудовали на гроші Москви.
Сьогодні Грозний здається мирним.
Але це лише на перший погляд.
Чечня стала центром релігійного фанатизму відтоді,
як "Ісламська держава" почала вербувати
тут бойовиків.
Високий рівень безробіття у цих регіонах,
соціальне невдоволення,
нереалізовані амбіції призводять до того, що ці люди
сприймають у збоченому вигляді те тлумачення ісламу,
яке подають джихадисти.
Джихадистам вдається вербувати чеченців -
незважаючи на те, що держава повсюдно стежить
за екстремістами, незважаючи на те,
що глава республіки Рамзан Кадиров
лояльний до Кремля і Володимира Путіна особисто.
За останні роки цілі сім'ї вирушили воювати
в Ірак і Сирію.
Влада робить ставку на роз'яснювальні бесіди.
Адже терористи продовжують вербувати нових бійців,
особливо серед молоді.
У це профучилище в Грозному.
Матері бойовиків "Ісламського держави"
прийшли, щоб розповісти історії
своїх дітей.
Ті були такі ж молоді, як і ці підлітки.
Їм було не більше 20.
Я дуже люблю своїх чеченців. Напевно,
я найбільша патріотка своєї нації заради Аллаха.
Але я хочу вас вберегти від тієї біди, яка палає
в мене всередині.
Я не можу знайти свою доньку,
мій зять загинув.
Такі особисті історії мають застерегти молодь
від неправильних вчинків.
Не бувало такого, щоб тут у технікумі
ми обговорювали таку тему.
Чому?
Ну не знаю, мабуть боїмося всього цього, навіть говорити про це.
Чого боїтеся?
Ми нічого не знаємо, може ми сьогодні заснемо,
а завтра наш брат туди поїде, ніхто цього не знаємо.
У тебе є знайомі, які там?
Ні. Я і не хочу знати.
Всі кажуть, що якщо піти туди, там буде рай.
Ні, звісно, не буде там раю.
Рай під ногами матері.
Але багато чеченців шукали рай в іншому місці -
в Сирії та Іраку. І, схоже, цей пошук для них
незабаром закінчиться.
Вони повертаються додому до своїх родин, на батьківщину,
де вони будуть терористами й убивцями.